welcome to episode 43 of the michaela
peterson podcast
in this episode i had the pleasure of
interviewing dr benjamin bickman
dr bickman is the author of why we get
sick
we discussed insulin resistance in
detail how to cure type 2 diabetes
why our current method of diabetes
treatment doesn't help
and why some people gain weight easier
and faster than others
the benefit of ketones in infants the
benefits and potential side effects of
metformin
and much much more this episode is
brought to you by
mertycreative.co they make leather goods
and gorgeous journals
the last time i spoke about them i
mentioned that i was getting andre a
journal for christmas
so here it is for those listening
it's brown it has his name
on the side it's pretty nice
he started using it already
they make great gifts i've almost used
up mine you can get
a journal to refill the leather portion
too so you can reuse them over and over
and over again
they make other leather goods too um
cupholders
binders etc if you use codemp you can
get free engravings
done they also do custom engravings if
you want them too
they also have a podcast
mertycreative.co
on youtube where they talk about
starting a small online business
which is probably something people
should listen to my advice if you have a
small business
or a large business and you haven't
started advertising on podcasts
do it it's new but it's very effective
so that's marty creative.co codemp
for free engravings this episode is also
sponsored by
my go-to meat company true local
t-r-u-local.ca
here's an example of one of their
beautiful steaks
very marbled if you use code mp you get
free steaks with your box
they hook you up with local farmers and
ship you sustainably raised meat
they have the best lamb i've had and i
get a box every two weeks with their
turkey rib eyes wild salmon
and lamb that's what i would recommend i
find signing up for a box like this
is a super easy way to get healthier
because you just have the food
there so that's what you eat so for the
new year's if you're trying to get
healthier this is an easy way to do it
plus it's yummy it's local it's
sustainable you care about that kind of
stuff
that's truelocal.catru local.ca codemp
for free steaks
i hope you enjoy this episode remember
to subscribe if you do
[Music]
dr benjamin bickman welcome to my
podcast oh michaela what a pleasure
thank you so much please call me ben
ben gotcha uh i have your book here
why we get sick which is quite a title
that's that's gotta cover a lot
so i'm very excited to get started yeah
it was a little
bold admittedly you know i i you got to
be a little provocative but
which i wanted to be i i that's always
fun for a boring professor to do
but i also felt it was justified based
on the on the data which we can
jump into yeah so i know that
there's a lot about insulin resistance
in there
and that's something that i don't know a
lot about i think most people haven't
heard of
and it's not something we've covered
before on the podcast so can we start
off with
maybe what is insulin what is insulin
resistance
why does it matter why should anyone
care yeah yeah
great it's a great place to start just
to make sure we have a common foundation
yet insulin resistance or insulin is a
is a hormone that we make from
certain cells in our pancreas and when
someone has type 1 diabetes
the disease is they aren't making
insulin anymore
and because insulin is essential for
survival the
therapy a canadian discovery is is the
use of exogenous insulin so they they
begin
a course throughout the rest of their
lives of giving themselves regular
insulin injections
so that's insulin and insulin does as a
hormone
uh it it's like any hormone it has
actions throughout the entire body
and insulin is no exception in fact it's
it's the ultimate example
of a hormone insofar as it literally and
i don't use that term
um liberally it literally affects every
cell in the body
every cell in the body has things called
insulin receptors which are these
very specific doors if you will on the
surface of every cell
from from bone to brain from lungs to
liver
they that where insulin can come and
knock on that door
and basically tell the cell to do
something
that that's the and one of its main
actions the one it's most famous for
is that it will lower blood glucose
levels when we eat something starchy or
sugary
blood glucose levels will start to climb
if glucose stays too high for too long
that's actually
dangerous even lethal and so insulin is
a savior in that sense
it will come to certain cells on the
body especially muscle cells
knock on the door of the muscle cells
open doors
for glucose to come rushing in out of
the blood into the muscle giving the
muscle some energy and other
tissues other cell types as well so
that's a general overview of what
insulin itself
is then insulin resistance is really
this
this it's two sides of a coin and not a
good one
unfortunately so this is where someone
has
some cells of the body that for various
reasons
have stopped responding well to insulin
so i mentioned the muscle cells a moment
ago
the muscle cells can become insulin
resistant and now an insulin comes in
attempts to knock on the door
to allow the glucose to come in the
muscle cell isn't responding it's
ignoring the knock
so to speak and so the glucose levels
will stay higher that's one
example of a cell that's becoming
insulin resistant
but not all cells become insulin
resistant
and that is where the other half the
other side of the coin becomes relevant
because the other feature of insulin
resistance the first being again that
some cells aren't responding
the other feature is that insulin levels
themselves are elevated
so they're chronically up so someone's
living a life
where every moment is spent with insulin
being several times higher
than than than it should have been than
it used to be when they were more
insulin sensitive
and that becomes a problem because there
are many cells in the body
that are still responsive to insulin and
now
insulin is over stimulating them insulin
is working
too well at those cells and one
interesting example
is the the thickest cells of the ovaries
so it's it's a little known fact that
the ovaries
um part of their job i promise this is
all still me defining insulin resistance
unless it seems like i've gone off on a
huge tangent
um it just helps to really understand
the two aspects of insulin resistance
with but the thicka cells of the ovaries
they are very busily converting
testosterone into the estrogens the
prototypical female sex hormones
and that's the little known fact all
estrogens and men yeah all estrogens and
men or women
used to be testosterone politically they
get converted
yeah well yeah but but hey i'm a
scientist
i think and i'm a scientist in the hard
sciences so i don't have to worry about
politically correct
i can just state the biological facts so
in men or women
the part of the job of the testes and
the ovaries is converting
testosterone into estrogens it's just
that ovaries do it of course a lot more
and ovaries do it through the actions of
an enzyme called aromatase now these
cells in the ovaries called the cells
they maintain their sensitivity to
insulin and so now
insulin is too high and and it's over
uh it's overactive at the fecal cells
one of the consequences here is that
insulin actually
inhibits that conversion from
testosterone into the estrogens
and so now you have a woman with with
this elevated insulin which is insulin
resistance
and now her ovaries are not producing
the big estrogen spikes that she needs
for a normal fertile menstrual cycle and
now the ovaries just start producing a
lot of follicles
and never one ovulating and so the
ovaries get really big and those little
follicles become cysts and now she has
polycystic ovary syndrome
which is at its core a disease of too
much insulin even in ladies that are
lean and you wouldn't think oh well
they're insulin resistant
they might not fit the profile um in
that they might be
they looked like their normal weight but
even in normal weight women with pcos
their fat cells have still become
insulin resistant
and that is pushing this insulin
resistance to the uh
elevating the insulin and that's then
compromising the function of the ovaries
so all of that was my
long-winded explanation insulin
resistance is this
two it's a combination of two variables
one
some cells aren't responding to insulin
and two insulin itself is much higher
than it should have been and the two of
those together
are really acting together that really
is what explains
why insulin resistance is so relevant
most people would just think
if they know anything about insulin
resistance they would think oh it's just
relevant to diabetes of some kind
but the truth is as i certainly
elaborate on in the book
at book length is that these two
variables of insulin resistance
really explain how insulin resistance is
a fundamental cause
of virtually every chronic disease and
if it's not causing the chronic disease
it's making it worse wow okay
because having i know for women having
uh cysts
it's fairly common even in otherwise
healthy people
that's what you're told anyway okay this
is interesting and it's fascinating
though because part of
the one of the most common therapies for
some with a woman with pcos
is to give her a drug called metformin
which is an insulin sensitizing
medication it helps lower the insulin in
the body
and i think it's 91 percent of all women
with pcos
respond well to this insulin sensitizing
drug it helps with the disease
so if you're put on uh metformin for
this
is there any explanation as to why it
works like do doctors say you know you
have an insulin problem
take this medication or they're just
like it coincidentally helps i don't
know
yeah yeah so in fact unfortunately i
suspect it's more often the latter
uh i am unaware of many um health
practitioners that elaborate this
metabolic aspect
of of pcos but it is known in fact i'm
good friends with the local
fertility expert here in utah valley and
he
he doesn't call it pcos i can't exactly
remember what he calls it but he recalls
he calls us something like metabolic
infertility
and that is so much more accurate
because pcos
just describes the fact that the ovaries
are getting loaded with cysts
that doesn't actually touch on the the
cause of it but causing it
invoking a metabolic origin to the
disease
helps us detect it i think with a little
more finesse and treat it much much
better
yeah that's how diseases should be named
but they're not right i mean even
something like
i i was eventually diagnosed my
diagnosis changed from rheumatoid
arthritis to idiopathic arthritis
and i was like i know i'm trying to
figure out why
too right that's not helpful idiopathic
no no to say we don't know why
thanks a lot yeah i don't know why
either but now it has a name idiopathic
joint swelling yeah unknown joint
swelling thank you that's why i came in
yeah okay so what do people
do okay let's start let's start here
what causes this in the first place yeah
yeah so
there is there are a few known causes
and and i i guess i'll break it up into
i think maybe the best way to describe
it is sort of primary
and then secondary in a way so the
primary
causes are three that i believe are
relevant in so far as
they they will directly cause insulin
resistance at
various cells like for example i could
grow up a little dish of
muscle cells in my lab right across the
hallway here and i could treat them
with these things that i'll mention in a
moment and the cells would directly
become insulin resistant
and so those are i mean and and i'll
kind of go in
inverse order of relevance i think the
first would be
stress uh so the the primary or the
prototypical stress hormones like
cortisol
and epinephrine those are directly
antagonistic to insulin and cortisol in
particular
so someone who's had to take like a
common course of treatment for example
for rheumatoid arthritis or any type of
arthritis might be
a cortisol analog like a problem or a
dexamethasone
and those will cause the body to become
insulin resistant very quickly
and then the insulin is going up and now
the fat cells are holding on to energy
more
and you've had jason fung on previously
so this is something he's very much
eloquent and elaborated on well in the
past so that's why the person taking
these anti-inflammatory steroids
they are cortisol like molecules they
cause the body to become insulin
resistant
and then all the consequences that come
from that and so that's one cause
chronic stress
um uh and then second actually
interestingly
having described cortisol which is
anti-inflammatory inflammation
is a distinct cause of insulin
resistance on its own and so
in fact let's mention rheumatoid
arthritis again that's an autoimmune
disease
and like most autoimmune diseases it
will have active and passive phases
you know the person their joints are
really bad for a couple days nah they're
all right now they're really bad
and that's very likely because of an
environmental exposure
as you would know better than most when
many autoimmunities are triggered
because of something in the environment
something they're ingesting
in some way shape or form so with auto
with rheumatoid arthritis it's
interesting to note that when
someone is in an active phase of the
disease
and they have higher inflammation higher
joint pain you can detect an increase in
insulin resistance
that ebbs and flows as the disease is
more or less active
so you can measure that you can yeah
there's a study that's been done in
humans to show that
yeah so that's the second one
inflammation is a cause
of insulin resistance and then lastly
the one that i believe is
is the most relevant in a long-term
situation is
too much insulin itself now someone
the astute listener would uh remember
from just a few minutes ago well wait
ben you just got done saying that
elevated insulin is a feature of insulin
resistance it is
it's also a cause and and we see this in
laboratory settings including from my
own
lab but in humans even if someone has
chronically elevated insulin
the body stops responding to the insulin
so too much insulin is a cause of
insulin resistance now some people balk
at that
um explanation but it really is
fundamental of of just biology
too much of a stimulus will result in a
resistance to that stimulus whether it
is a hormone
whether it is an antibiotic whether it
is a a drug
whether taken for medicinal purposes or
abused the person will need
more and more of that drug to get the
same response that they used to get from
a smaller amount so insulin is no
exception
when a stimulus is incessant at a cell
the cell will start to turn down its
sensitivity to that signal
and so too much insulin is one of the
primary causes of insulin resistance and
then
the the last one that i just i need to
mention is more of a secondary
because i can't induce insulin
resistance for example on cells
by directly treating the cells with this
molecule but that would be the omega-6
um polyunsaturated fatty acid linoleic
acid
so the fat that is abundant in in uh
these artificial seed oils uh like
soybean oil or or you know in canada
in alberta you always see these canola
fields canola oil
is is is the same it's these in these
really i guess industrial seed oils that
100 years ago had no place in our diet
and they are more of an indirect effect
because they make the fat cells
become insulin resistant and when the
fat cells become insulin resistant
they're typically the first domino to
fall
and i won't elaborate more beyond that
lest i get off on a whole other topic
but insulin resistance is sort of this
process of one
tissue falling like it would be the
first domino
and i believe it's the fat cells that
become insulin resistant first
and in so doing they then start bumping
into other tissues like muscle liver
brain
etc let's just assume most people
listening
who are having any health problems
probably already have it
so once you already have it what do you
do and then
then we'll cover how do you just prevent
it in the first place
yeah yeah in fact uh michaela i i in in
all likelihood
uh most people listening although you
might have a bit of a unique crowd that
is healthier than average
um so might not apply quite as much yeah
or
that's right maybe they're more
desperate yeah more just the desperate
people are like i'll listen to the meat
girl yeah yeah no no well said
that's a good point so a study um from
the
from the unc school of public health at
the end of last year
they published a paper which is it's a
survey-based paper which is always a
little problematic but they found that
of of us adults were considered
metabolically unfit
because they failed in one category of
of the metabolic syndrome which is sort
of this constellation of five health
disorders
uh before it was called the metabolic
syndrome it used to be called the
insulin resistance
syndrome and so what is what's relevant
about that statistic that
you know almost nine and ten adults are
metabolically unfit
we kind of take that one deeper level
and i don't think it's
too much of an assumption to then say
well that might mean nine in ten adults
is is insulin resistant and
unfortunately because of how we view the
disease
which i won't elaborate on yet because
that is a different topic
but we we don't diagnose the insulin
resistance we diagnose the manifestation
of the insulin resistance we tell the
woman
you have pcos we tell the man you have
hypertension
um you have fatty liver disease
whatever it is all of these disorders
that the average
clinician or the average clinical visit
wouldn't imagine
has a common core but they do and i
certainly go into detail in the book
and that's one of the points of the book
it is to emphasize that
there is a common cause of most diseases
and and that's a good thing
because then we can treat one thing we
don't have to give them a drug
that's treating the symptom which is
really all a drug can ever do
a drug can never cure a disease it can
only ever treat
symptoms and so there's i think there's
something kind of liberating
about this perspective that there is and
i'm not saying insulin resistance is the
sole cause of chronic disease not at all
i'm not so bold or naive to say that
but it is definitely a big part and that
should be good news because that is
something that is one
single point of attack that we can
address and and so then
rather than this so you imagine a
typical overweight canadian or american
and he opens up his medicine cabinet he
has to take his anti-diabetic drug
his anti-hypertensive drug to control
his blood pressure
and and you know maybe one more for his
erectile dysfunction
and then realize i mean imagine how
liberating it is to realize wait a
minute
i can get rid of all those medications
which are simply all
um addressing symptoms of one common
problem
insulin resistance and so to your
question uh what about the solution
in fact the solution for reversing
insulin resistance is the same for
preventing it so i can kind of address
both of those issues in one
in and i believe firmly the most
effective
rapid way of reversing insulin
resistance is to lower the insulin
change a person's eating habits to bring
the insulin down
and now all of a sudden the body becomes
more insulin sensitive
and the lower insulin itself those two
events together we have removed the
insulin resistance
and all those all those surrogate or
derivative problems
begin to resolve the person's blood in
fact blood pressure
is so intimately a result of of insulin
resistance that within days
of someone changing their diet to lower
their insulin they have to get off their
anti-hypertensive medications because
they start fainting their blood pressure
has gone so low so quickly
and the same thing within weeks of
anti-diabetic drugs like
dr jason fung has shown within just a
few weeks
of a person changing their diet they
have to stop
taking their insulin injections for a
type 2 diabetic because
they don't need it anymore their glucose
is going too low
so it is a it's a phenomenal
it's a liberating i use that word too
often it's but it is
it should be looked at as very good news
where someone can say i can
i can save money i can save on the side
effects of these medications i don't
like how they make me feel i don't like
taking them
well the good news is the gospel of this
is that you can change
you can change it the food you eat is
either the culprit or the cure
and again if you look at it as a cure
you look at it through the lens of
what uh will this keep my insulin low
and that is why the default then if we
if someone listening to this would say
okay great ben well how do i do that
the solution is simple it it really is
but that doesn't mean it's easy because
when you start to talk about changing
someone's habits
yes that's that is hard to do um
especially with food
you know it's not like i could tell
someone who's smoking i'd say well just
stop smoking never smoke again and
you'll be better off for it
it's not that easy with food because
it's not like i can say just don't eat
anymore
you have to eat and so they're
constantly surrounded by that temptation
to eat the wrong foods to let it be the
the culprit rather than the cure but to
let food be the cure
it it really is as simple as control
your carbohydrates
avoid those foods that are spiking your
insulin
which are refined starches um you know
and sugars which are abundant they're
they're ubiquitous they're everywhere
nowadays
whether it's serbia or singapore or
canada or anywhere else
they're everywhere and the sooner we
start controlling carbohydrates focusing
on the least
starchy and the least sugary foods then
the sooner insulin can come down
and now the body starts to almost
seemingly miraculously
heal itself but it has to start with
controlling carbohydrates
and then of course the person would
think well what do i eat then if i can't
eat bread and bagels and cereal
then focus on protein and fat those are
not only essential there are such things
as essential fats and essential amino
acids
while they're as you know better than
most there's no such thing as an
essential carbohydrate
but i'm not saying don't eat any carbs
i'm not i'm not saying that
but focus on the foods that we actually
need proteins and fats
and coincidentally have little to no
effect on insulin
so someone can eat a big juicy steak and
their insulin will barely have a hiccup
it'll barely move i wear a continuous
glucose monitor on my arm
and when i do just for fun very very low
carb weeks or even carnivore weeks which
i do from time to time to just
i do it to check my addictions that just
to make sure i'm
keeping my diet in check and i'm not
kind of getting into
i just i detest i have horror addictions
of any kind
it's part of my one of my personal
philosophies i don't want to be addicted
to anything
and so when i sense addictions cropping
up in my diet i will actually go on kind
of a water carnivore week to just check
those addictions
to put them in their place when i'm
measuring my glucose on my
my continuous glucose monitor it is a
flat line
literally the whole time except for when
i exercise it'll bump up which is
typical it's supposed to do that
it'll be a flat line every meal you
won't even know i've eaten
it doesn't react at all so that's the
good news someone doesn't have to starve
they don't have to count calories
um shift the focus of your of your diet
to to control carbohydrates prioritize
protein make sure you're getting enough
high quality protein which is always
animal
and then um don't fear fat um
acknowledge that fat is essential it
comes with protein for a reason
eat it that way when i first went low
carb and i didn't even know
what i was doing was low carb at that
point i was just cutting out
randomly cutting out foods when i was 23
that i thought might
be bugging me uh yeah it was within a
month
that i saw absolutely incredible like
life-changing
resolutions of symptoms i'd had for over
a decade
instantly i also went into severe carb
withdrawal which i didn't even know
was a thing like i didn't know that i
was addicted to some of the food i was
eating yeah yeah
and i got rid of almost all my
medications
and now i know i did that too quickly
like one of the things you have to be
careful of is some of these medications
you actually get used to
and you can't just stop but i threw them
all away which i would not recommend
right yeah but it it was completely
mind-blowing
i had like six i don't know how many
different diagnoses i'd had
it was just i just kept adding them on
and i was like who cares at this point
right if you have more than
three who cares yeah and it was so
mind-blowing to
figure out that oh my god there's one
underlying cause and for me i was like i
knew it was certain foods and they
turned out to be high carb foods
um although pork still irritates me so
there's something something there
sometimes
monogastrics what about what about
chicken you know what
it's not the same and i haven't tried
something like wild boar
so i'm assuming it might be what they
eat because i can do wild salmon with
absolutely no problem
um and i can't do even if it's organic
if it's
farmed uh it doesn't make me feel good
it's not like eating grains but that's
so uh chicken is okay but it also
depends on
i think what they're eating more than if
i'm eating
uh rooming into animals yep yeah
i'm not a voice in the carnivore space
and i shouldn't be but
i am a huge advocate of ruminant um
animal consumption of ruminant animal
products in the human diet
there's something just beautiful it's
elegant it's intelligent
that this is an animal that can eat a
food that nothing that we cannot
we cannot eat those grasses uh at all uh
so this whole kind of vegan myth that we
can eat like an
ape does we can eat like a cow does no
we cannot
we cannot thrive on that kind of diet so
to be able to
have an animal that can take a plant
like grass which is directly getting
energy from the sun
and then captures that energy harnesses
it and because of its miraculous
stomachs can form all the foods it needs
and then we as apex predators can then
come in and eat that animal they can't
eat any of the other
grains and plants that we might want to
enjoy they're not supposed to eat those
they're supposed to eat the plants that
we cannot eat and thank heavens for that
i think there's something
beautiful about it yeah yeah i know it
it's crazy
so you talked about you mentioned
metabolic syndrome which was actually
one of my questions because i wanted to
say
i've had doctors come on and talk about
metabolic syndrome
and i actually don't really know what
that is very well
yeah but that's just got like i i didn't
have time with those podcasts
yeah so what is metabolic you have the
professor here so let me let me
teach you yeah so metabolic syndrome as
i mentioned is a constellation of five
disorders
and over the years there have been a few
kind of rolling definitions of it
but the consensus has settled on these
five let's see if i can rattle them off
one is elevated blood pressure so
hypertension
second elevated glucose levels
third elevated waist circumference so
central
obesity or adiposity and then the fourth
and fifth are kind of related which is
just sort of bad blood lipids and
specifically they break them up into two
elevated triglycerides and low hdl
what's so interesting that's the end
that's the end of it so if someone has
any of those
or to varying degrees then they would be
defined as having the metabolic syndrome
but again to my earlier point
metabolic syndrome is is a vague term
that doesn't help you understand
the origins of these problems so i
resent the use of the term metabolic
syndrome
but i appreciate that it's certainly
more compelling it's more provocative
it's sexier
than saying the insulin resistance
syndrome but when gerald reeven first
came up with that term
um what was the origins of what we now
call the metabolic syndrome he called it
the insulin resistance
syndrome and dr reevan was just sort of
this famous diabetes scientist
which means to say he's not famous at
all unfortunately
why would any diabetes scientist be
famous when we look at it as
insulin resistance syndrome now we
understand the origins of these problems
if someone is insulin resistant
they will have elevated triglycerides
they will have the lower hdl
if they're insulin resistant they will
have higher glucose and higher blood
pressure
and the central obesity can both be
cause and consequence
of the insulin resistance itself but all
together those constellation of
disorders
it is are much more derivative or more
accurately described as consequences of
insulin resistance
rather than just a vague uh you're not
metabolically
fit you know that that's too vague that
doesn't help anyone they're left
like you were saying earlier that's just
saying you have an idiopathic metabolic
problem well thanks
thanks for telling me can i get my money
back yeah
okay that makes sense i didn't know that
those were the same things
yeah they are yeah that's interesting
that's good to know
especially for future podcasts talking
out of their doctors exactly pretending
but they might not know it though
michaela the the sad fact
not to throw not to throw physicians
under the bus which i i truly don't mean
to
to do or sound like i'm doing um i
appreciate that these are front line
individuals
but the reality is in this in this world
that a physician
they get paid a physician gets paid to
see patients
that's the job of the physician i'm a
scientist
i get paid to ask questions now i don't
get paid as well it's not as lucrative
to be curious
as seeing patients but that does mean i
can sit back
and say how does hypertension
um have a metabolic origin why is it
part of the metabolic syndrome
oh it's because of the insulin doing
this and doing that
throughout the body of blood vessels at
the adrenal glands it's affecting the
way the body's behaving
with regards to its blood volume and
blood pressure and so that's
i know that and so my greatest my most
favorite audience is actually when i get
to go
give toxic clinics about these kinds of
things i love
speaking to nurses and doctors and
hospital administrators
with no ego it is not my ego that drives
that interest
it's because there's a genuine delight
on my part
to think this is the way it ought to be
there ought to be the scientists in the
lab the boring kind of their version of
white coats
finding answers to questions they convey
those answers to the actual
practitioners
who are on the front lines doing doing
all kinds of
you know wonderful things but they they
don't get paid
to sit back and kick up their feet in
their desk look out their window and ask
themselves these questions
they would be fired if they did that i'm
a tenured professor i can do that all
day
and so when i can take that information
and give it to a physician
or a nurse who can then put it into
practice
that is my greatest hope and indeed if i
have any lasting legacy
whether it's from the book or from my
career it would be
that there would be a handful of medical
practitioners who have
heard me say something like what we've
been talking about
and put it literally into their practice
directly improving their patients
well-being
yeah that's going to be tricky though
like um i
from what i've heard about medical
school and and what you get taught there
a lot of it's from pharmaceutical
companies there's money there and
there's a lot less money telling people
not to eat certain foods
right like oh yeah plus your patients
wouldn't come back for very long
i'm not very happy with doctors at the
moment or like since
for a while since since changing my diet
reversed a whole bunch of diseases that
were
chronic that were genetic that i was
never gonna get over and then
i tried to explain that and was
ridiculed i'm not i'm not that
thrilled with the medical system to be
honest well that's no i
understand completely and i certainly
feel frustration in my own right with
how people look at type 2 diabetes
the average clinician will look at type
2 diabetes as completely a glucose
problem and they'll say
your glucose is too high and they won't
have any awareness of insulin insulin's
not even on their radar
but the tragedy in this situation is as
someone's developing insulin resistance
as the audience now knows
their insulin is high but the insulin is
enough there's enough
function of the insulin that it's able
to keep the glucose
at normal and so the patients coming in
they get diagnosed with pcos
or or hypertension or fatty liver
disease and they're not even looking at
the insulin
if they did they'd see that it's much
higher it's only years later
that now the body's become so resistant
to its insulin that now the glucose
starts to climb
and then they detect the problem they
say ah well you have type 2 diabetes now
and the tragedy doesn't end there but
that's the first tragedy
is that by looking at type 2 diabetes as
a glucose disease
we detect it too late potentially
decades later if we looked at it
as an insulin disease we would detect it
much much sooner
and second if we looked at it as an
insulin disease we would treat it better
because the tragedy in type 2 diabetes
is the type 2 diabetic
has very high insulin and very high
glucose but because we look at it as a
glucose disease
the physician will say well let's just
give you more insulin let's put you on
insulin therapy or give you drugs that
will push up your insulin
and they might not even know what the
insulin is but it works to lower the
glucose
and so if this were just a glucose
disease we would say well we've solved
the problem
but the reality is when we give a type 2
diabetic insulin
and they already have high insulin which
they always do in type 2 diabetes
then we make them fatter and sicker and
we kill them faster their risk of dying
from heart disease triples
the risk of dying from cancer doubles
the risk of getting alzheimer's doubles
we are killing them by giving them
insulin but kind of to your point the
cynical view that i
somewhat share conventional medicine
would just say you can continue to eat
high carbohydrate diets
in fact eat every two hours just make
sure you cover it with insulin
that is an asinine perspective
it is killing patients when we put a
type 2 diabetic on insulin
and tell them to eat what they want and
just cover it with insulin
it's a wonderful way to sell more
insulin but it's a terrible way to help
a patient get better
and and with if we look at it as an
insulin centric or through an
insulin-centric paradigm
then we say all right you have
chronically high insulin how can we
lower your
insulin you know what eat less carbs you
don't have to go zero carb to do this
just eat less carbs we published a paper
a clinical case study with a
clinic here in my area and we took 11
middle-aged women with type 2 diabetes
full-on type 2 diabetes
and we put them on a they had an option
when they were in that clinical visit
having just been diagnosed with type 2
diabetes the option was you leave with a
drug
prescription the consequence of which
will be that you have to continue to
take that drug forever
and you'll likely have higher and higher
doses of it or
you have a a nutritional prescription if
you will and it's going to be
the simple rules that i outlined earlier
control carbs focus on protein and fat
and within 90 days these 11 women but
were part of the case study they elected
to follow the low carb
even ketogenic diet and within 90 days
they had
nary a whiff of diabetes their glucose
was totally normal
they had lost 20 pounds their blood
pressure had come down by
any definition of the disease we we had
cured it which is a term you're not
supposed to use
with type 2 diabetes you're not supposed
to say you cure it because if you just
use drugs to
solve the problem well you never will
you will never cure it
wow that gave me goosebumps yeah well
it's certainly a load
to just dump there but anyway but really
if anyone listening
who who knows someone and they most
certainly do or they're struggling with
type 2 diabetes themselves
i would want them to hear this taking
insulin
and using it um as a bludgeon
a blunt tool to just smash the glucose
down
um and eat whatever they want that's the
worst way to address this problem
and by giving the patient more insulin
with insulin therapies
we're killing them yep that's not even a
dramatic
like sounds dramatic but it's like
accurate
yeah uh okay let me let me think where
to go from there
okay so say somebody is listening to
this podcast and is now concerned
that they're insulin resistant which
they probably are if they're on a
high carb diet is there a way to to go
to their doctor
and check their blood or something to
get some
concrete evidence yeah that excellent
question in other words so we've been
defining the problem how would someone
identify it
yeah now that we've defined it yeah yeah
so unfortunately we don't identify it
because we don't look at insulin so one
of my
really my central thesis um in the book
in a way is we need to put insulin on
the radar
including measuring it clinically so now
in canada actually
um and in the uk um it's almost
impossible to get insulin you've really
got to jump through some hurdles
because there's such a reluctance to
devote resources which are so finite
in those medical systems despite their
strengths and i'm not saying they're
it's only weakness
but it's very difficult to do it's
easier of course with a
a private a more private medical system
like in say switzerland or even the u.s
but my point being measure the insulin
measure your insulin is someone who's
hearing this and is about to have a
clinical visit
do what you can beg plead whatever
to get your insulin measured and
once once you've done this you've you've
gotten your fasting insulin hopefully
it's your fasting insulin
that gives you one direct measurement of
how you're doing
and if the fasting insulin now
unfortunately of course there's the
the metric or empirical units across the
u.s and canada in the u.s
so anyone listening can make this
conversion on their laptop later on on
on
a browser but it's six micro units per
mil is
what i consider to be the cut off for
being really really good
insulin sensitive if you're below six
six or below or if it's higher than that
then it's just getting into a more
problematic range
in pico moles which is how they measure
it in canada i think it's around 30 to
35 or in the uk anyone listening who's
overseas
very likely your insulin is going to be
measured in picomoles that's going to be
around 30 or 35.
um nevertheless that's one measurement
measure your fasting insulin
and if it's below 6 micro units per ml
or or around 30 35 pico molar
then that's a good sign and you're doing
great a second measurement is actually
looking at your blood lipids and this
one's a little more
accessible because we always were so
obsessed with blood lipids
which which is fine i don't think that's
unwarranted
but that means someone will always have
their triglyceride number
and their hdl number the hdl cholesterol
and so this sort of poor man's method a
surrogate
of getting a feel for what your insulin
sensitivity status is
take your triglyceride number and divide
it by your hdl cholesterol number
and if that ratio triglycerides to hdl
cholesterol
is 1.5 or less now think heavens the
units here don't matter because they'll
be comparable in the us or abroad
then if it's 1.5 or less that's a good
sign
that's a person who's insulin sensitive
in general so though to sum it up
get your insulin measured and if you
can't get your insulin measured due to
insurance constraints or medical system
constraints then focus on your
triglyceride hdl ratio you will always
get that measured no matter where you
are
and if it's less than 1.5 then that's a
green light you're doing all right
interesting i'm going to get blood work
done
hopefully it'll be out when this podcast
comes out
just after three years of just eating
meat
uh so maybe i can maybe if you go to a
naturopath too if you can't go
can't get it through your doctor you can
usually get those more
those more specific tests to the natural
path so that might be a way to do it as
well
yeah yeah i agree and i think in those
instances although you might know better
than me
they have a little more liberty in part
because you you have to just be prepared
to pay a little more
yeah it's expensive you usually have to
go for a consult which is
a bunch of money and then buy the tests
but you they will do whatever you ask
yeah yeah that sounds right yeah okay
so switching directions completely but i
think this is something we should get
into
why is it that some people gain weight
much easier than other people um
what a great question um and i will
start answering that by saying there's
not a clear
answer but let me let me speculate a
little bit
so what it is not is metabolic rate
so that's one of the great myths so the
the great myth of weight gain or weight
loss is
you have some um 20
year old you know dude who's bragging
about
you know i of course i have them all
over here because i'm a university
professor
he's bragging about how he can eat
whatever he wants because he has such a
high metabolic rate or you have some gal
and she has her roommates and she is
envying one roommate oh she can eat
whatever she wants
her metabolic rate is so high or you
have people like who are older out of
school
oh i gained 10 pounds or gained 20 or 30
pounds once i got married or once i had
a baby
my metabolism just really slowed down
all of that is totally false
there's nothing to support that um
perspective at all
in fact with pregnancy in mind a part of
the great
it blows that myth apart quite quite
well because the moment a woman becomes
pregnant
over the next nine months her metabolic
rate is going to get faster and faster
and faster
because metabolic rate is just the sum
of all the chemical reactions happening
in the body
building things up and breaking them
down anabolic and catabolic
that is metabolic or metabolism or
metabolic rate
and so metabolic rate does not predict
weight gain in fact there was a study
someone anyone could look up called the
baltimore longitudinal study
and they basically followed a bunch of a
bunch of guys about a thousand people
for ten years and they measured
metabolic rate at year zero
in a year ten follow-up what their
baseline metabolic rate had been at year
zero in no way predicted
who gained or lost weight the most or
the least in any
to any degree however in that same study
there is
an ounce of explanation for what might
have predicted their weight gain or
what might have been responsible for it
and they looked at something called the
respiratory
exchange ratio the rer
is a measurement of what fuel we're
burning now very briefly
human metabolism is like a hybrid where
at any moment
the overwhelming majority of all the
energy our cells are getting
is coming from a mix of carbohy of
glucose or fat
so blood sugar or fat that's the main
fuel and it it's a mix that all the time
we're never burning just one or just the
other
all the cells in the body are using
these two fuels and shifting between
them as needed
maybe because they've eaten or because
they've fasted but basically the rer
will tell you are you more sugar burning
or are you more fat burning what they
found
was that the people that were more sugar
burning that that glucose was
responsible
for the majority of the fuel their body
was using they were the ones who gained
the most weight
in contrast the people that were more
fat burning
they gained the least amount of weight
they were the more likely to stay lean
so that's that's that's relevant uh
where we look at
not metabolic rate but rather what is
the primary metabolic fuel that person
is using and what's so interesting about
this so someone hearing this would say
okay well i don't want to be a sugar
burner then
because then my chances of gaining
weight over the next years is going to
be higher yes that study would suggest
that's true
then the core the follow-up would be
well how do i then become a fat burner
really the there's this old adage where
we say
you are what you eat and that is
absolutely false it's silly on its face
what the more accurate version of this
would be you burn what you eat
and unfortunately because we are such a
carb
obsessed culture and it's not just in
north america i've given talks of
similar veins in asia and the middle
east in fact the middle east it's even
worse than it is in north america
metabolic problems that is uh but but
the world is obsessed with carbohydrates
you'd mentioned your sort of carb
withdrawal no tasty
yes exactly no one is sitting around on
a saturday night
about to indulge in some in some shows
some tv shows or movies
and they're thinking oh i sure want to
play the scrambled eggs
no no okay just to interrupt i watched
the jungle book with scarlet last night
yeah and we had chicken wings
chicken wings chicken wings and salt so
super crispy
but in our popcorn bowl so there are
some people
who are doing that but it's fairly rare
it's very rare
it's very rare because we want although
you kind of addressed
part of it because we are craving
something that is salty and crunchy or
sweet and gooey
and that is always almost always going
to be carbohydrate now you actually
found a clever way around it by just
picking a chicken
yeah yeah so that worked but it's it's
people are typically craving
carbohydrates now back to my point
unfortunately
because we're obsessed with
carbohydrates and we eat every two hours
we are constantly in sugar burning mode
and it's only once we lower the carbs
and or fast
do we shift over to fat burning mode
where we can
we can shift between these fuels and
once again
insulin rears its relevant head and even
in this process
because insulin as it hor this hormone
is what dictates which fuel we're using
if insulin is elevated we are oblig
obligatorily burning
glucose we're sugar burning if insulin
is low we
shift and we start fat burning in fact
if insulin is low for an extended period
of time
like 16 to 20 hours we start burning so
much fat
that we actually are burning more fat
than we need so to speak
and some of that fat gets metabolized
into ketones
and that is why an insulin that keeps a
diet that keeps insulin low
is called ketogenic really because it's
burning fat like gangbusters
it's just tearing through the fat in the
body it's burning it at such a high rate
we start making ketones from it and and
but
back to the point if you're fat burning
you it's easier to control your weight
because if those fat cells are not
filled with glucose
they're filled with fat and it's only
once we start burning fat can we
actually start to control our body fat
if we're stuck burning sugar all the
time those fat cells are never touched
in a general way in a generic sense and
thus they just keep pulling in energy
never actually using it because we
aren't burning fat we're mostly burning
glucose so
if someone so why why might someone be
gaining weight more easily than another
part of it could be that just
the composition of the foods they're
eating and their inherent differences in
insulin sensitivity
insulin resistance is genetic where some
people will just
be more insulin resistant than other
people because mom and dad were
grandma and grandpa were so there
there's definitely a genetic component
to it
so those people that are more insulin
resistant naturally they will have to
fight harder
their insulin is going to want to be
higher all the time
and so it'll be a harder fight for them
to keep it low but they can
do it and and once again the truth of
the situation is it's not their
metabolic rate
it's really this what fuel the sentiment
of what fuel are you burning
and the kind of background there is what
what is your insulin level
if insulin is high you're burning sugar
you're not burning fat
and the insulin is going to stimulate
the fat cells to grow and store energy
rather than break things down
did you say that fat cells can store
glucose
um yeah well no i said that fat cells
wouldn't be storing glucose
so fat cells don't have a capacity to
okay
to create glycogen like the muscle and
the liver does and a few other cells
whatever glucose they pull in they
either use it for fuel or they convert
it into fat
which depending on the size of the fat
cell the fat cell can do very well
a fat cell is perfectly capable of
pulling in glucose
and when it when it has a lot of glucose
it can convert that into triglycerides
which is stored fat
okay so i have a question uh when i when
i first started fasting so i went to the
carnivore diet and then i
i had this pregnancy and there was some
weight that i still couldn't lose even
on a
ketogenic carnivore diet and i started
fasting which
made me feel really good but when i
first started it didn't make me feel so
good
and i would get body odor and i just
didn't feel very good and i was losing
weight and then after about
four months that stopped and now when i
fast that doesn't happen
and i was i've always wondered if that
original
fat that i was burning wasn't as healthy
as the fat i later created because i
changed my diet
is that at all possible oh well it's
certainly possible yeah so fat
cells do act as reservoirs for all kinds
of chemicals
um that we consume and when a fat cell
is shedding its fat it is also releasing
other chemicals and these can be things
like um
uh diethyl stilbestry stilbestrone which
is in plastic same with bpa
bisphenol a that can get stored in fat
cells so there are molecules that will
be stored in fat cells but the degree to
which they will
create problems once the fat cells
releasing them i don't know that's just
too far from my area of research um i
would however
this is prompting me to make a to share
some note of caution
um following childbirth that is one of
the times where a woman
needs to be careful with carbohydrates
and in fact not putting them too low
actually and especially if she's
breastfeeding
i don't know man it improved my life i
went zero carb in my br and i started
producing more
breast milk i was quite concerned about
the only reason the only reason i say
this
is because if a woman's adhering to a
strict ketogenic diet and she's
breastfeeding
it it can increase her ketones so high
because
during breastfeeding she is burning fat
so readily
to enrich the fat in her in her milk
that she can get into
a dangerously high level of ketone and i
only say that
because like you just said i actually
know a woman who's a type one diabetic
who thrived on a local she's a type one
diabetic
thrived on a low carb diet throughout
her whole pregnancy thrived on a
low-carb diet throughout all of her
lactation period
and never had a single negative episode
and it thrived truly she loved every
minute of it
but i only say this note of caution
because there are some case studies
published
showing a woman whose ketones have gone
so high that she's gone into acidosis
which most people can never get into i
could not eat another scrap of
carbohydrate for the rest of my life
zero glucose and i would never even come
close to ketoacidosis
most people just can't do that lactation
is this kind of metabolic anomaly
that allows her to accelerate
ketogenesis and part of that could be
that the mom is wanting to enrich her
own breast milk with ketones
because babies thrive on ketones and
even a newborn baby
baby will eat and two hours later baby
is in deeper ketosis than an adult can
get to
in three days of fasting so cool yeah
and it feeds
in fact this is a shout out to a
canadian scientist named stephen cunning
in quebec of all places which is hard
for me to admire anything in quebec
because i'm from alberta
and you know we don't have a little jab
because we get that
yeah canadians understand yeah exactly
yeah especially anyone from the west i
was born in montreal so i feel like i'm
allowed to say that
yeah that's right yeah um and i just
like i can poke fun
at bald guys you can poke fun at quebec
so so in this instance the baby is
really um
gobbling up the ketones and it appears
to be a very human
adaptation where the brain is our brain
is so big and is so hungry
that ketones especially in a newborn are
very readily providing that fuel and i
mentioned stephen cunning because anyone
who's interested
in in finding out more about the brain's
use of ketones
whether it's in human development or in
pathological situations like alzheimer's
disease
stephen cunningham has been a wonderful
authority in this regard for years now
so it's proper for me to give a shout
out to him
but to kind of sum it up a woman might
need to be more careful
you clearly thrived in it and i know
another gal who also did
i just feel compelled to mention it
because of these couple case studies
that have been published
yeah yeah well i mean i didn't thrive i
was like limping along after i gave
birth
because my for a number of reasons but
it definitely
dramatically improved my life that's
great
to go into ketoacidosis how would
somebody on a low carb go into
ketoacidosis i
thought that that had to include a
high glucose level yeah yeah so
ketoacidosis is
virtually impossible unless you're a
type 1 diabetic
so me mentioning the non-type if a woman
doesn't have type 1 diabetes and she's
lactating and adheres to a strict
ketogenic diet
she might get into ketoacidosis but more
often than not would not
but that's really the only instance
unless you are a type 1 diabetic
and you mentioning that ketoacidosis
happens in the context of high glucose
it's because if a type 1 diabetic is
under dosing their insulin
they're not taking enough insulin now
they aren't pulling in glucose very well
into their muscle cells and other cells
so the glucose gets really high
and because there's so little insulin or
none if they're not taking any insulin
they are burning fat like gangbusters
and now they're producing a
massive amount of ketones to the point
that it's changing the ph in the body
making their blood acidic so that you
know so keep ketoacidosis
so ketoacidosis is generally a problem
of a type 1 diabetic who's not taking
enough insulin
now just because it's so interesting i
have to
i feel compelled to mention this some
type 1 diabetics
deliberately under dose their insulin
they're willing to flirt with this
dangerous ketoacidosis
and glucose levels that are 10 times
higher than they should be
and feel miserable because they've
learned that if they under dose their
insulin they can stay as thin as they
want
and imagine for the listener imagine the
temptation because
insulin completely it has a choke hold
on our fat cells
if insulin is up fat cells will grow if
insulin is down
fat cells will shrink that's just the
reality that's the biochemistry of the
fat cell
and so this type 1 diabetic imagine the
temptation if you're especially say a
young woman
in your early teens and you you you get
diagnosed with type 1 diabetes you've
been losing weight over the subsequent
months
you are rail thin you then go into the
hospital
you get diagnosed with type 1 diabetes
you start to feel better as you're
treated with insulin but you notice
that you now can't fit there are
instances of a gal going into the
hospital
with uncontrolled type of diabetes
leaving a few days later and she's
gained so much weight already with the
insulin she can't fit into the same
clothes she
entered in and so she learns through
just experience
i can eat that chocolate cake that whole
thing as much as i want
i don't have to starve myself i don't
have to throw it up
later all i have to do is not poke
myself with this
damn needle and give myself some insulin
and i can stay as thin as i want
that's imagine that's actually a
disorder called diabolia
which is just sort of this clever term
bringing together the diabetes aspect of
it
and then uh in eating disorder like like
um bulimia which it isn't
this is a it's a sort of a a
thermodynamic
bulimia whereby not taking the insulin
she simply
cannot store the energy as fat it's
impossible
wow and so and so the tragedy imagine
that temptation
imagine yourself with a needle and all
she does
she doesn't want to do anyway but you
get to enjoy that indulgence
you could you could do a savor it you
chew it you swallow it you have the
satisfaction of keeping it
in your in your stomach digesting it you
know
perfectly well but it just floats in
your blood and so
it's tragic to say this but when i have
my students
write when i teach them this principle i
want to emphasize not only how
how tempting it would be for the patient
if they ever see this in their clinical
practice
but but the tragedy is that the patient
will die early it'll be
miserable because they will have they'll
die from keto acid
acidosis or long-term massive
hyperglycemia but they will look
great in their coffin that's the tragedy
is that the the what they're willing to
do to their bodies in order to stay thin
but it reflects just how powerful
insulin is in controlling whether
someone's gaining or losing weight
wow yeah and well and also most of these
people don't understand that if they
went low carb
then they might have improvements right
so they're like no i i get that
i had uh i was on immune suppressants so
i was i've been injecting
i don't anymore but i was injecting
myself with medication twice a week from
the age of eight until 23. it was
absolutely miserable made me nauseous
like
it took like a year it took years to get
used to because you're not supposed to
psychologically be able to harm yourself
like that even though it's supposed to
be treating it so
i i totally get that uh
that's that's very concerning and so
it's important to educate people that
there are actually
ways you can go about oh treating that
yeah
even in type 1 diabetes people may think
well once again they're fed that myth
eat all the carbs you want just cover it
with insulin no all it does is set the
type 1 diabetic up
for this constant roller coaster and the
anxiety that comes with it
where they didn't take enough insulin
now their glucose is too high or they
took too much insulin now their glucose
is too low and they got to rescue it
this was a published study in type 1
diabetics type 1 diabetics that adhered
to a low carb diet
focusing on protein and fat which have
very little glucose and insulin effect
their glucose just went like this it
just turned in rather than these wild
swings
it just hovered along along as hovering
around normal
all the time that is the way to address
the problem
not by this myth of eat whatever you
want and cover it with insulin
it doesn't work yeah
okay um i think what i want to end with
is i've heard a lot about the drug
metformin
and i'm from from my experience of
taking
a plethora of medications and what their
side effects were and how they affected
me
i'm generally of the opinion that people
should
navigate their health by changing their
diet and not ingesting
any pharmaceutical unless they they're
dying
right so i've heard a lot about the
benefits of metformin the anti-aging
properties
maybe everybody should just take this
drug and i'm skeptical because that
seems like a bad idea
but what do you think about metformin
what is it
should people take it is it healthy what
a great question
so i agree wholeheartedly with your
sentiment when it comes to drugs
someone should i think a drug is only
warranted if the disease is caused by a
lack
of whatever the drug is going to provide
so for example insulin which
really shouldn't be called a drug but a
type 1 diabetic must take it because
their disease is
i don't have insulin a person with
a chronic thyroid disorder they have to
take thyroid hormone because their
diseases
i don't have thyroid but diabetes in any
way shape or form or insulin resistance
isn't caused
by a lack of metformin this artificial
pharmaceutical molecule so
we could never expect it to solve the
problem and it doesn't of course it just
addresses some of the symptoms
but metformin will lower insulin and
improve insulin sensitivity
which is why it is the most widely used
anti-diabetic drug
um any now what's interesting about
insulin is that insulin is
a strong signal for aging there is this
focus um on on you know delaying aging
how can we live longer
and there is a strong sentiment that
part of the problem is this hormone or
this protein in cells called
mtor now people various listeners might
have heard of mtor
basically what these researchers have
found
is that if you reduce mtor then the
organism will live longer you know the
mouse will live longer the little fruit
flies will live longer
of course we can't do this kind of
evidence in humans so they'll never be
conclusive evidence in humans
but nevertheless that's the sentiment
you inhibit mtor and this has led
for some to eat less uh it
has it has led some people to the
conclusion they should eat less protein
because dietary protein will activate
mtor so people have created
a diet that they say is it like it's
like it's mimicking fasting
and you'll live longer by eating less
protein
that is so ridiculous and the human
evidence refutes that sentiment
completely
because the there's a study shown that
when
people are over the age of 65 now it's a
correlational study so we can never take
it too far
but over the age of 65 people that eat
less protein
die more well that challenges the
sentiment that if you're eating too much
protein
you'll die early because the people that
were eating the most protein were living
longer
so we have human evidence that directly
challenges that sentiment
but the mtor evidence is still
compelling
the evidence that activating mtor
chronically will promote aging
and prevent cells from basically
activating autophagy and staying young
in a way and then all the cells of
course by some the
by extension the whole body staying
young
but if someone is invoking mtor
and they they're saying we need to keep
mtor turned down more often
all the more reason to keep insulin
turned off because insulin activates
mtor more than protein does
and so if you eat a steak you're getting
proteins which is activating mtor that's
good because it's telling for example
the muscles and the bones
to make proteins from those amino acids
so it's good to activate mtor we need it
turned on
sometimes but the problem with insulin
is
based on people eating high carb diets
every two hours they're snacking on
these
treats then their insulin is elevated
all the time and
insulin is keeping the mtor chronically
turned on so if someone is
wanting to age well i would say
keep insulin low and there's evidence to
support that including evidence i go
into in the book
and that has led some to conclude well
then metformin could be used as an
anti-aging drug
because metformin will help the insulin
be down the evidence does not support
that in fact there is a rodent evidence
to suggest that that does not happen at
all explicitly
that metformin does not promote
longevity and moreover
there's human evidence to suggest that
when someone is taking metformin
if they're exercising as well the
metformin is so damaging to the
mitochondria
in cells that it actually is mitigating
the benefits of the exercise
wow so this drug is undoing the benefits
of the exercise and the person is
likely exercising to live longer and be
more insulin sensitive
and the metformin is mitigating some of
those benefits so i
am not an advocate of someone taking
metformin
because they think they're biohacking or
something clever like that
if you are a type 2 diabetic or a person
with insulin resistance
and you want to control your pcos or
your hypertension
i think there could be a place for
metformin it is effective at improving
insulin sensitivity
but there are consequences and like with
any drug
you're just hoping that the consequence
you want namely the improved insulin
sensitivity
is worth the consequences you don't want
like the gut damage the liver damage etc
because every drug
all you get is side effects and again
you just hope that the side effects you
want
are worth the side effects you don't
yup where can people go to find you
online
yeah yeah thanks uh so the book is
available for sale anywhere books are
sold
it's a cliche to say that but it's true
and we've covered a lot of some of the
details here and if someone wants more
details the book's a great resource in
that regard um i am fairly active on
social media
and my whole purpose of social media is
simply that of a scientist educator
i'm not i i don't get personal i i sort
of i abhor
sharing too many details about me and my
my you know my
preferred you know hair products or what
have you so
my involvement on social media is mostly
on instagram in fact it's interesting
michaela i've gone through this
evolution when i started on social media
probably four years ago
it really was to overcome the hurdle
that's inherent in
in biomedical research which is that i
could make these
interesting findings about human obesity
and diabetes and no one would ever know
because i publish a manuscript and and
the only
person who reads a manuscript are the
same small group of scientists
and i'm the only i'm part of a small
group who reads their manuscripts and no
one ever knows about it
yeah so i got involved in social media
as a vehicle
simply to be to directly share
information with people
about metabolic health so i'm more
active on instagram people can find me
there on ben
ben bickman phd but my point earlier
or what i was going to make is that i
started on twitter but twitter has
become
such a vile yes it's just filled with
such angry
um people who just are so desperate to
be offended
and to spread their offense and to point
a finger at whoever they perceive
offended them that
i i admit i'm sort of losing patience
for twitter
and and then going more leaning more to
instagram which at least at the moment
just has a
generally nicer crowd in my experience
so that's where people can find me also
i encourage anyone to look at a website
get
health and health is spelled hlth part
of i won't elaborate here unless i seem
like a shill
but even wanting to be more of the
solution i i thought
uh there just isn't a great low carb
meal replacement shake and so i
i did it i i made one um and and that
people can learn more about that shake
it get health
hlth.com interesting yeah it's been a
fun it's been a fun venture actually
but it was really just me sensing
there's not when you go low carb as you
know better than most
um or as well as anyone there's an
inconvenience to it
uh because that means you can't eat
processed foods anymore
and and so this was an effort to try to
say all right well if someone's really
busy they want to do low carb this is a
good way to do it but nothing i'll say
this i'm not in any way implying that
it's better than a good steak
um you know when it comes to eating food
real food like steak and eggs
is the way to do it but where someone's
looking for a little convenience then
this might be a good alternative
oh i found what completely changed i
wish i worked for air fryer
an air fryer company honestly it
completely changed my life i spent
three years and it was so miserable
because i was in university
i was like okay i can't go eat out with
my friends that's fun
i'm eating a whole bunch of food i don't
know how to cook that i don't really
like because i'd rather eat sushi
and i'm spending like two hours a day
cooking all this stupid stuff
it was so annoying and i had a baby and
it was like
now i have to cook with a baby and then
i got an air fryer
and it completely changed my life and i
just eat like frozen steaks into the air
fryer and take it out
like i said maybe i'll make that into
something the michaela area
i'm curious though i have an air fryer
i've never tried making a steak in it
though do you have to sear it
no so you have to cook it from
frozen even if you get fresh steaks
freeze them seems like a bad idea but
freeze them
put them in cook them on cook it on the
highest temperature
uh and you don't want the ones that are
like this thin
the best ones are about this thick so
like
even two inches right but because it's
frozen on the inside it doesn't cook
all the way through so you can end up
with a medium rare or a medium steak
that's crispy on the outside because it
takes 20 minutes
it's magical it's life-changing so good
so you put it on the max setting for 20
minutes
yeah if you have a steak that's about
this big you do 10 and 10
but under do it cut it if it's too rare
stick it in for a few more but the trick
is freezing the steak and then there's
there's no prep
it's wonderful genius yeah so so modern
technology is certainly making low carb
easier every day
yeah thank goodness well thank you very
much for coming on
this is the book why we get sick i would
highly recommend checking it out
uh and that was absolutely fascinating
so thanks again for coming on
oh my my pleasure my pleasure it was
such a delight to be able to get on here
and talk about all these things i hope
i'm certain we've discussed some really
relevant points anyone listening
i think can can come away feeling
edified they've learned something
relevant
yeah i hope so i think so dude thanks
again
[Music]
you